what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and the Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
trailer just drop let's not waste any
time let's dive into it we knew it was
probably coming today I'm actually kind
of shocked it did though but I'm really
excited so let's do this
we're gone
for quite a while
but no matter what happens next
the Galaxy still needs its Guardians
hello we come in peace oh it's counter
Earth
yep
for the high level
come on Drax seriously dude
[Music]
don't forget
it's Rocket's origin story
the high evolutionary
we have been running
our whole lives
I'm done running
oh there he is
done we'll all fly away together
one last time
[Music]
[Music]
there he is on Warlock
[Music]
yo
[Music]
and we'll kill anyone who gets in our
way no not kill anyone kill a few people
he'll know people kill one guy one
stupid guy who no one loves now you're
just making it sad
wow okay
all right well we briefly got a look at
Adam Warlock right there
I'm okay
I'm okay with uh this I've always been a
fan of Will Poulter
um I always thought that if he bulked up
a little bit he could do really good at
this and it looks like he is going to be
doing a great job here I really like it
it's interesting how they kept the the
stone in his head because that's
supposed to be the Soul Stone the soul
gem from the comics he looks pretty good
here though looks pretty good here
though let me know what you guys thought
about this trailer down below I really
liked it of course it's uh well actually
it doesn't say it's a teaser trailer it
says it's an official trailer but I'm
sure it's a teaser I'm sure we'll get
another official trailer pretty soon ish
maybe a month maybe two but in the
meantime let me know what you thought
about this trailer down below gonna get
started on my breakdown so be sure to
look out for that in probably about an
hour or so so I'll catch you guys in
that video woof woof